[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva edición
especial de reporteros en una
colaboración entre france24 el diario
español 'el país' un equipo de
periodistas de ambos medios se desplazó
hasta el departamento de arauca
fronterizo con venezuela allí desde
enero se han producido más de 160
homicidios en un conflicto entre el
ejército de liberación nacional lln y
las disidencias de las farc el epicentro
ha sido el municipio de saravena donde
luís muñoz y juan diego quesada que nos
acompaña en el día de hoy tuvieron
comprobar desde cerca el estado de este
conflicto armado lluís empiezo con usted
de parte de nuestra casa de france 24
como ha sido esta experiencia en arauca
en primer lugar raúl muchas gracias por
invitarnos a este reporteros en segundo
lugar tampoco quería olvidarme de
agradecer a quienes han llevado la parte
visual de este reportaje y en el puse
ring videógrafo de france 24 y camilo
rozó fotógrafo del diario 'el país'
también por último quería comentar que
esto ha sido un viaje de cinco días que
inició en yopal en el departamento del
casanare y continuó sobre todo en
saravena el epicentro allí pudimos ver
carros bombas testimonios de víctimas
pero también otras cosas detalles
cotidianos que indican ese conflicto
como está vigente como por ejemplo el
impuesto revolucionario que grupos como
lln cobran a la población o también
hechos en las zonas rurales como median
en conflictos como divorcios entre
personas juan diego ruiz habla de estos
conceptos y le quería preguntar a usted
porque se han dado estos enfrentamientos
ahora raúl mira esta zona de colombia es
un paso estratégico para el trasiego de
drogas a venezuela que es de donde se
distribuye al resto del mundo lo
controlaba históricamente lln y después
las las disidencias de las farc hicieron
una incursión y durante un tiempo los
dos grupos estuvieron conviviendo pero a
partir del primero de enero iniciar una
guerra que claramente va ganando el ln y
ahora mismo es la que tiene más el
control de esta región pues juan diego
luis gracias vamos a ver este reportaje
y ya regresamos para una pregunta final
[Música]
3ds dice
bueno vamos a iniciar movimiento táctico
motorizado desde el puesto de mando en
saravena
atentos al movimiento misiones
los riesgos que se pueden presentar en
esta zona es la instalación de
artefactos explosivos sobre la vida
en colombia todavía hay guerra en
saravena en el oriental departamento de
arauca 78 personas han sido asesinadas
desde enero es un municipio de 43 mil
personas la tasa de homicidios por
100.000 habitantes es de 181 si se
mantiene la proyección de asesinatos
sería una de las tasas más altas del
mundo dos guerrillas el ejército de
liberación nacional y las disidencias de
las extintas farc luchan por el control
del territorio
estas son las instalaciones de lake al
instituto colombiano agropecuario de
sarabela línea caminas sobre las ruinas
en las que su padre trabajaba como
guardia de seguridad aquí el 19 enero
exactamente a las 10 35 de la noche un
carro goma flotó en la parte del frente
del icap un atentado terrorista hacia el
edificio que se encontraba al lado fue
la respuesta de las disidencias a las
decenas de homicidios selectivos
cometidos presuntamente por el ln a
principios de año en medio del conflicto
también quedan los civiles como si me
han delgado
yo esperaba todo menos común era una
manera tan fea
en colombia hay más de 9 millones de
víctimas después de cinco décadas de
conflicto el del inei es el dolor de la
guerra
mi papá quedó totalmente
la bomba iba dirigida contra este
edificio sirve de casa para distintas
organizaciones sociales como la
fundación joel sierra el principal
objetivo de las disidencias de las farc
los acusan de colaborar con el ln y si
quiere someter nosotros desde la
fundación de derechos humanos también
contamos con el servicio de una
psicóloga que pudiera ayudarla así usted
quiere también en atención el día de la
bomba les avisaron de que algo iba a
pasar unos 60 líderes estaban en el
edificio la dirección que tomó la onda
expansiva les salvó como pueden ver con
nuestros propios esfuerzos se ha logrado
al menos de esto me dio a avanzar en en
acomodarnos un poquito porque el daño
fue gravísimo a esta estructura la
fundación trabaja en la defensa de los
derechos humanos una profesión de riesgo
desde la firma del acuerdo de paz de
2016 entre el estado y las farc más de
1300 líderes sociales han sido
asesinados en colombia
porque con un día que intentaron borrar
los de la faz de la tierra
un día yo creo que vivimos nosotros
estamos haciendo las cosas bien porque
se intentarán matarnos
es una falla gravísima de este estado y
sobre todo en un municipio tan
militarizado un departamento tan gritar
izado con arauca
a dos horas de saravena está la boca del
lobo del conflicto en medio l tcr
filipinas un centro poblado de
reincorporados de las extintas farc
les visitan las naciones unidas- la
iglesia y la defensoría del pueblo
no entendía qué colores que nos
desbordamos para que tenemos
nelson quinteros jefe del espacio ha
hecho un llamado de emergencia
hemos recibido una amenaza latente una
amenaza de que tenemos que desocupar el
departamento que teníamos que irnos del
departamento y no es fácil porque
nosotros somos personas en el proceso de
la incorporación los firmantes de paz
también están en riesgo en colombia más
de 300 han sido asesinados desde el
acuerdo pero además de muerte
desplazamiento 80 familias de ex
combatientes han salido de arauca de un
total de 3.000 desplazados desde enero
que nos digan si podemos seguir en el
territorio ayudando a construir o
tenemos que desplazarnos
a donde no tenemos adónde ir
vamos estamos en la espera qué va a
pasar con nosotros en filipinas la
coyuntura ha obligado a alonso mendoza a
dejar en pausa su huerta personal pues
me gustaría que de alguna manera nos
pudiéramos quedar que los actores
entiendan que nosotros no tenemos nada
que ver con conflictos con guerras pero
sin embargo continúa implicado en los
proyectos comunitarios como la cría de
cerdos
así vas a comer más arriba que abajo muy
mal
y los cultivos de plátano
pues el plátano se siembra por colin o
que llamamos decir un ratón y todo es
con se arranca se arregla y se siembra
sí y ahí sale la matriz el departamento
de arauca es el segundo productor de
plátano de colombia una alternativa de
éxito para dejar la coca atrás pero la
gente se ha mantenido en decir no vamos
a trabajar el campo de forma legal eso
es muy agradable para nosotros los
excombatientes que estamos en proceso de
reincorporación y que ayudamos a motivar
esa política de sustitución en el año
2002 en arauca había 2 mil 215 hectáreas
de coca en 2018 fue declarada por el
gobierno colombiano como región exitosa
en sustitución de cultivos ilícitos
la iniciativa de acabar con las
plantaciones fue de los campesinos
después de que en 2010 el eln y las farc
llegaran a un acuerdo de paz tras una
cruenta guerra iniciada en 2006
cocinada si quiere le traigo toda la
banda a preparar un segundito
en aquel conflicto previo la vida de
fernando serrano era muy diferente no
tenía su restaurante en saravena sino
que era concejal
fue secuestrado y algunos de sus
compañeros fueron asesinados
entre 2006 y 2010 hubo más de 1000
muertos
ln y las farc se enfrentaron por la
injerencia en política los cultivos de
coca la extorsión y los negocios en la
frontera
finalmente quienes están confrontados
somos los de abajo los de arriba
sencillamente han manejado los hilos del
títere para poder de pronto el poder
donde están y meternos una guerra y una
psicología terror de que nos vamos a
transformar como en otros países cuando
realmente la desigualdad que vivimos en
el nuestro es totalmente
que supera los límites de frontó del
análisis
estos son los tanques de almacenamiento
donde convergen este grueso es el
oleoducto bicentenario
y el delgado que vamos a ver al lado de
allá es el oleoducto caño limón-coveñas
para que es rica en recursos como el
petróleo
a pocos kilómetros de saravena el
ejército custodia con más de 40 hombres
sus dos oleoductos bien bueno me alegra
muy bien gracias por el trabajo que
realizan en caño limón sellaron dos mil
millones de barriles de petróleo en 1983
colombia pasó a ser un país exportador y
empezó la bonanza petrolera
hoy arauca genera el 7 por ciento del
crudo del país
este ha sido fuente de financiación para
los grupos armados de ahí los múltiples
enfrentamientos con la fuerza pública
miedo no no siento miedo no yo creo que
uno siempre va acompañado de dios soy
muy apegado a dios y desde que uno tenga
la protección de ese ser
glorioso que está desde arriba
protegiéndonos vamos bien
jorge eduardo mora es el mayor general
que controla la octava división
la mayor de colombia él es el quinto en
la línea de mando
como lo habíamos
esta mañana vamos a a
desde yopal casanare departamento
fronterizo con arauca controlar todo lo
que pasa en el oeste del país y está la
brigada 18 en arauca es prácticamente
todo el campo de combate de arauca el
mayor general jorge eduardo morán
muestra una sala de guerra eso esos tres
pilares de contener proteger y atacar
las áreas bases sus campamentos sus
cabecillas nos ha dado los grandes
resultados operacionales pero en arauca
el conflicto va mucho más allá de los
combates los grupos armados logran una
gran injerencia los dos últimos
gobernadores de partidos de derecha
están encarcelados por nexos con la
guerrilla marxista leninista de ln
cooptación que logran también entre la
sociedad civil el apoyo a los grupos
armados ha pasado de generación en
generación son muchos milicianos que
tienen también que se dedican ellos en
hacer inteligencia delictiva en hacer
ataques terroristas en atentar contra el
oleoducto en colocar cargas campos
minados
entonces es una amenaza híbrida que no
solamente el componente armado es el
único que hay que atacar
el ejército cuenta con más de siete mil
hombres en el departamento los
homicidios se han ido reduciendo desde
enero arauca tiene 450 kilómetros de
frontera con venezuela
la falta de relaciones diplomáticas
entre ambos países favorece el
movimiento de grupos armados y economías
ilícitas pero arauca también recibe
influencias políticas del vecino
socialista como monchi quien es líder
social en el barrio hugo chávez de
saravena el nombre fue aprobado en
asamblea un revolucionario digo yo la
palabra revolución pendón de armani nada
eso es de todas aquellas personas que
está en contra en sistema si pues de
este barrio se tiente por eso y por la
humildad de la gente
es un barrio de invasión formado por
desplazados y víctimas del conflicto
monchi denuncia estigmatización me dicen
de dónde viene la dirección entonces uno
a la dirección y el nombre del barrio
hugo chávez y una vez lo tildan a uno
como guerrillero
me miró goyeneche estuvo en prisión tres
años fue detenido en 2003 durante las
capturas masivas del gobierno de álvaro
uribe muy buenos días a todos los
oyentes de noti frontera el saludo
cordial emiro es periodista en salar
exterior habla el aire habitualmente del
conflicto con el padre joaquín es
llamado con legalidad siempre hace miro
y es un llamado a que especialmente a
los actores del conflicto a que saquen a
la sociedad civil
el conflicto pero también a que respeten
la vida
emiro cuenta con un equipo de escoltas
fue amenazado en enero por disidentes de
las farc y mi situación es bastante
complicada en temas de seguridad pero
hay que seguir con la tarea en medio del
conflicto armado que vivimos nosotros
los jóvenes le apostamos a la cultura y
le apostamos a salir adelante y en cañas
está harta de los estigmas como que
llamen a su pueblo sara bomba en su
lucha organiza este evento de cultura al
parque con emprendimientos y música
en una armonía
como ya podemos ir logrando por medio
del llano intermedio
a pesar de la guerra los araucanos se
vuelcan en el evento después de décadas
de conflicto se acostumbraron a no
acostumbrarse
y hago lo necesario para terminar
y seguimos conversando con los dos
autores de este reportaje juan diego o
vuelvo con ustedes para preguntarle
después de cinco décadas de este
conflicto hay una solución si
seguramente si el estado colombiano pone
todo el interés solucionarlo podría
hacerlo de hecho ya los candidatos
presidenciales que quedan en la segunda
vuelta rodó fernández y gustavo petro
hablan de llegar a un acuerdo con él lm
y con las disidencias básicamente los
dos tienen el mismo enfoque de acabar
con ellas de forma militar o
policial y lluís realmente también les
repito la pregunta que dice juan diego
hay una solución se pudiera llegar a un
acuerdo de paz con él en coincido con el
compañero juan diego y la verdad es que
tienen que apostar por esa paz como ya
hicieron con las farc en 2016 cuando se
logró ese acuerdo histórico que
desmovilizó a la guerrilla más grande
del mundo pero también hay que tener en
cuenta las particularidades de un grupo
armado como el ejército de liberación
nacional elñ ln en el que pese que hay
unos mandos que se cree que están en
venezuela o que puede estar
teniendo ciertas conversaciones de paz
también hay que tener en cuenta que es
una estructura mucho menos organizada
que la de las farc donde también hay
disidencias internas que siguan al
margen de los mandos que emiten sus
comandancias gracias yo hice entonces
por esta respuesta y gracias también
juan digo por acompañarnos aquí en
france a ti 4 por este reportaje
esperemos tenerlos una vez más aquí en
este estudio con un nuevo reportaje en
colaboración entre francés de 4 y el
país ustedes continúen con nosotros
hasta una nueva edición de reporteros